Madam President,
ladies and gentlemen, Members, dear
President of the Council, can only three thoughts
at the end of the one answer to ketscher of the gentleman, Members
of Parliament,
we have increased the
connecting europe facility for energy by a large majority
overall, and
europe's energy policy has always been made up of
three goals:
sustainability, climate protection,
first, second, security of supply,
and third, affordability of energy.
in recent years,
countries such as poland, for example, or
latvia lithuania estonia have expected that they
will need gas for as long as we need it  for heat and
electricity gas do not need 100 percent
of gas from the russian federation
of gazprom depend and therefore
diversification of routes and
sources
this would have to new parliament so
decide what role should gas in the
energy mix e  uropes in the years 2020
2030 2040 150 play
my guess as long as we will
switch off coal gas will get in next 10 15
years which in turn will
have a sinking there is also green
gas a vision why should i be produced in africa
from solar plants green
gas that in lng  terminals in
europe is fed into the gas network and can thus play a
climate-neutral and sustainable role in the
energy mix of tomorrow and the day after tomorrow
the decision is up to you
in the next parliament and
the majority of the money goes into
power lines and infrastructure
across borders in order
to complete and circulate the internal market for energy
bringing renewable energy to where it is
needed renewable electricity quantities
, for example from
ireland wind power via england to the
european union
we will decide on the projects at a
later date but since the list of applications is
long more funds are
definitely sensible
i want than  second  point to
thank the finnish presidency again why we
have reduced the budget estimates for administration through an amendment,
since salaries will only
go up slightly next year
and that celica have not served you the
reflex of previous years,
namely what in the last second
15 million cuts fifth  weeks was
sovereign
best thanks for that you can be sure
that none of the institutions
parliament court of auditors court of teachers
commission european schools etc will get
too cocky but we will examine very carefully
what will be necessary for proper
administration of europe in the next year and
years to come
final thought if you tomorrow
, honorable deputies
, i cannot agree to this budget,
this is the first important decision of the
new parliament, but will refrain from the election of the
president and others and
allow me to talk about the
role played by the top candidates  en
functionally how much lost you
didn't manage a majority that now
a
broad encourages us all and my bike
keep the goal to a broad more
on the home straight the budget framework
so the next decade at this
believes to have been years at home
best thanks
thank you progress  i think correct
intervention warns parliament and
thus more free willing compromises
bückeburg or is that of course was
the party are compromises costs
whether the individual
priority will have priority on railway construction group on
a group individually occupy we
are they are says not what by
eric hettmann maus  gives almost historical
fortress is out of caution offers committee
moment europe china politics technology
in europe constructive depravity of europe
and wants side used the end of october
ready
for that the coming spree went around
guilty informed jaffé young mother was
made to constructively and
creatively comp  romisse can be more condensed at the
moment it would be surprising
trust respectful open-
heartedness what we have there with the youngest stasi
to beijing has a happy ending red earth
according to the reporter
monika in edelrath segro gloomy
president jörg zicke creaks at him and two
weeks we are allowed to do something like that there  info other
sails with hanging message hearing
provisional things i can't be
a bridge contribution from hanson team
comeback which was very good but probably again the
best customer a brief
outline thanks to the belgian barony jobs is for
culture but the procedure has so far been
electronic